on voit des français qui se cherchent
parfois et qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux
attendent des mesures fortes des
candidats à la présidentielle alors
emmanuel macron mail mener parfois dans
les sondages peut-il reconquérir à les
français on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme daté france et place à
notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
julien audy le porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir junien en
dessous là vos côtés à distance cyrille
isaac sibille député modem du rhône
bonsoir monsieur issaka sybille merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
dont le gouvernement macro un qui n'est
pas à la hauteur il ya une franchise à
voir et elle n'est pas dans le camp
macron vois ça voici en substance un
stadier diène coubard qu'on a entendu un
le décrochage de deux portraits vous
comprenez la critique sybille isaac
sibille vous vous ne trouvez pas
spécialement justifier
mon politique j'ai la mémoire
la mémoire c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à cinq ans
souvenez vous il ya cinq ans roche qui
mouille à saint côme il ya cinq ans il
ya deux mois enfin au moins au mois deux
au mois d'octobre
2010 est 2016 excusez moi c'était alain
juppé qui était le grand public
au mois d'octobre
il ne peut pas au mois de novembre et
n'hésitez pas à ce moment tenant fin
novembre c'était françois fillon qui les
vendre à duke
souvenez vous aussi à cinq ans le
président sortant françois hollande
était amené à renoncer à être candidat
tellement il était impopulaire
maintenant regardons la situation
actuelle on n'a jamais eu un président
enfin on n'a jamais une politique d'un
plein de la république aussi soutenu par
les français à la veille d'une élection
présidentielle
donc moi j'entends j'ai bien entendu le
reportage passionnant j'entends que le
prendra qu'on ne peut pas faire
l'unanimité
mais je crois que la confiance dans la
politique qui m'aiment et
la confiance spontanée est au dessus de
45 % moi c'est ce que je lis dans les
études d'opinion
et donc la campagne présidence de la
campagne présidentielle bien évidemment
va nous réserver des surprises il ya
cinq ans a réservé elle nous a réservé
beaucoup de surprises nous qu'il faut je
pense dans le cadre de la majorité
présidentielle ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
reste calme on a un bilan pour la
défendre et il ya des propositions qu'on
va faire et les français décideront mais
j'en dis j'ai bien entendu votre le leu
leu leu reportages précédents on le
souhaite on ne peut pas faire
l'unanimité
alors va laisser répondre à leur deal
qui réagissait sur ce plateau qui vous a
laissé parler on va quand même un julien
hohl avant de vous laisser répondre
voire un petit peu ce qu'il en est on va
montrer un sondage intentions premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
sondages et labo pignon 2022 pour bfmtv
emmanuel macron 23% pécresse 20% marine
le pen 15% eric zemmour qui continue un
petit peu a chuté 14% deuxième tour
valérie pécresse 52% emmanuel macron 48%
alors il faut être honnête il y avait un
deuxième sondage rire qui montre l
inverse avec emmanuel macron quand même
l'emportant je viens en double est ce
que votre interlocuteur ces îles et zach
sill il a raison emmanuel macron il
n'est pas si détesté plutôt plébiscité
par une partie en tout cas des français
beaucoup plus que ses prédécesseurs à
cette époque avant la présidentielle bon
on se rassure comme on peut la réalité
c'est que il ya cinq ans emmanuel macron
il avait un projet aujourd'hui l'un
bilan et ce bilan force est constater
qu'il est déplorable il est déplorable
on n'a jamais eu un quinquennat aussi
fracturé aussi bouleversé où les
français ont été divisés et on a eu la
crise des gilet jaune qui a laissé
énormément de traces qui n'a jamais été
réglée par le président de la république
les préoccupations des gilets jaunes sur
le pouvoir d'achat sur comment dirais-je
le droit à la parole par la
proportionnelle sur une invisibilité qui
aujourd'hui totalement
ahurissante en france les questions qui
ont été posées n'ont pas été accompagnés
de réponse on a un président de la
république il faut bien dire qu'ils sur
tous les volets volet social volet
économique a échoué sur la scène
internationale notre pays a été humilié
notamment lors de la crise des sous
marins avec avec l'australie et puis on
voit bien que ce président de la
république finalement a été déconnecté
des français déconnectez leurs
préoccupations déconnectés de leur
quotidien ils les a méprisé dans le
verbe et dans les politiques je vous
rappelle pas là l'italie les petites
phrases qui ne sont rien il ya qu'à
traverser la rue pour trouver un emploi
les gaulois réfractaires etc et puis le
bilan il est clair c'est 6 millions de
chômeurs c'est plus de 10 millions de
pauvres c'est un français sur trois qui
n'arrivent pas à se soigner pour des
raisons économiques
c'est un français sur cinq aujourd'hui
notre pays qui ne mange pas à sa faim le
président de la république avait dit
lors de sa dernière campagne que plus un
seul français ne dormirait dans la rue
on a 4 millions de français aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont mal logées on a des
centaines de milliers de sdf on a des
étudiants qui ne mangent pas à leur faim
qui font la queue aux restos du coeur
c'est ça le bilan donné mais le mâcon et
s'il avait la lucidité de son mentor
françois hollande il tirerait les
conséquences de ce bilan et ne se
représenterait pas parce qu'ils sont
bilan est calamiteux je vais vous
laisser répondre série les acteurs
civils ce que je vois que vous réagissez
mais avant je voudrais vous faire passer
une règle son télégramme 1 on a posé la
question aux téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron alors est-ce qu'il peut
reconquérir les français en tout cas
pour ceux qui ne sont pas déjà conquis
on va regarder pascal 17 ce message
reconquérir encore faudrait-il les avoir
conquis car si ça avait été le cas il
n'y aurait jamais eu besoin d'ordonnancé
de 49,3 il n'y aurait jamais eu de gilet
jaune ni deux manifestations
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse
sylvie de isaac sibille c'est vrai que
les gilet jaune ça a quand même marqué
ce quinquennat et entraîné une forme de
rupture avec une partie des français
alors deux choses je sais pas si vous
avez un vaste recensement exact mais on
n'a jamais utilisé carlos iii vous
décrire sans doute référence à françois
hollande
deuxième chose pour mon contradicteur
monsieur ou double est ce qu'on vit
vraiment dans mon pays j'ai je ne crois
pas
regardez je prends quelques exemples
regardez la crise la crise la gestion
des crises était très critiqué
dans le sens où l'on donnerait un fait
qui aurait fallu faire regarder nos pays
voisins
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne
on a un meilleur élève regardez ce qui
se passe en autriche
regardez ci cependant tous les pays de
l'est mais ouvrez les yeux je sais pas
si les bijoux vers la france est un des
pays qui a mieux géré la crise sanitaire
d'autres exemples
entre guillemets vous bail du chômage le
chômage est au moins à cette façon il
est inférieur à ce qu'il était au début
de la crise on est on n'a jamais eu
d'aussi par un chiffre aussi par du
chômage depuis 10 ans s'envole de la
catégorie confession yul il y avait 2
millions maintenant la croissance on n'a
jamais eu croissance pour remonter une
présence pareil il faut remonter à 20
ans monsieur nous mais ce qu'on vit dans
un pays la crise sanitaire la baisse du
chômage la croissance entre guillemets
on est actuellement les meilleurs élèves
je sais pas je sais je sais pas si on
vit vraiment jamais ça ni soufre qui ont
voulu dire sutil et peur vous ne devez
pas dire cette année les meilleurs
élèves c'est impossible monsieur c'est
indécent parce que très sincèrement je
pense que c'est vous qui est dans une
bulle et c'est vous qui avez des
oeillères parce que peut-être qu'à
l'assemblée nationale tout va bien mais
allez un peu sur le terrain il ya des
français qui souffrent qui ont été
déclassés qui ont quêté que totalement
ébréchée par la politique que vous avez
mené depuis cinq ans qui était une
politique de fracturation sociale une
politique totalement injuste et ne me
parlez pas de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
excusez moi mais sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ça a été lamentable du
début à la fin monsieur véran qui le
ministre du mensonge monsieur virant le
ministre du mensonge que ce soit sur les
masques sur les tests sur les vaccins
parce que clairement aujourd'hui on en
est à la troisième voire quatrième d'eau
si on en croit monsieur delfraissy ce
matin donc ça va être finalement sans
fin se passe sanitaire qui est une
injustice majeure et qui n'a au met
donc ça c'est votre bilan je je je pense
que quand on s'y aussi vous aviez la
lucidité de regarder ce bilan en face
vous ne seriez pas là en train de
plastronner parce que clairement les
français les français voient ce bilan et
vous disent mais qu'est ce que vous
faites encore à votre place qu'est ce
que vous faites encore à votre place et
j'espère que dans quatre mois ils vont
vous renvoyer à vos études alors on va
vous montrer une autre réaction
télégramme et et jeté une petite
parenthèse un pont notre interlocuteur
qui parlait du 49 30 auteurs ce n'était
pas nous inciter un message cd g
emmanuel macron si mes souvenirs sont
bons l'avait brandi en tout cas on avait
brandi la menace pour les retraités et
oui il n'a pas utilisé parce qu'il ya eu
cette pandémie et finalement la réforme
des retraites et est envoyé aux calendes
grecques si j'ose dire leur meloche nous
dit v 9 78 son bilan n'est pas si
mauvais mais si en plus il baisse la tva
pourquoi pas civile isaac sibille c'est
vrai qu'il ya il ya cette question du
pouvoir d'achat qui va être l'un des
thèmes principaux de cette campagne il
est déjà parce qu'il faut pas oublier de
le dire l'inflation est de retour dont
peut-être aussi la la campagne que mène
emmanuel macron dans les dans les
départements ruraux le pouvoir d'achat
oui on non est-ce qu'il a augmenté sous
emmanuel macron parce que l'insee dit
oui mais il ya si j'ose dire a ressenti
des français comme nous le dira généraux
donkey et pas toujours en adéquation
avec ces chiffres officiels
comme vous le dites il échoue actuelle
l'insee indiqué huy et gtalk européen
entamés crise si plus tôt
entre guillemets
on a plutôt bien traversé la crise par
rapport au point d'achat b bien
évidemment il faut faire face les
notamment à l'augmentation des des
matières premières de l'énergie si les
causes extérieures la france auquel tout
le monde est confronté ne dit pas non si
si si si c'est un phénomène mondial le
détail ce monsieur c'est 60% de taxes
sur le prix des carburants donc arrêtez
cette action venue
du bar électro les avait éliminés c'est
inattendu % de temps et vous n'avez
jamais
jamais à aucun moment vous n'avez voulu
baisser les taxes sur les carburants sur
l'électricité sur le gaz qui sont au
plus haut et qui sont même plus haut
qu'au début de la crise et gilet jaune
et pire encore c'est à dire que vous
maintenez une taxe sur une taxe c'est à
dire la tei cpe la tva sur la tnt pu à
chaque fois que nos compatriotes vont à
la pompe ils paient une taxe sur une
taxe vous n'avez jamais voulu supprimer
cette aberration fiscale qui est une
spécificité française clairement que
nous rassemblons nationale nous avons
demandé notamment par une proposition de
loi de nos députés l'abrogation
voilà donc arrêtez de vous retrancher
derrière les cours de change pour vous
monsieur ne voulait pas aller j'ai levé
swing les messieurs monsieur vous êtes
dans le sentiment moi je suis dans le
fait non je suis la
réalité c'est quoi c est ce qu ont
augmenté les taxes non est ce que le
prix des matières premières augmentent
et oui est-ce qu'on est encore là dessus
est-ce que vous avez baissé les taxes
non voilà non
le fardeau de nos compatriotes c'est un
joueur shirin le meilleur projet qui est
clair c'est rendre 200 euros de pouvoir
d'achat par mois à chaque ménage
français par la baisse des taxes voilà
que ce soit pour l'être pour les
énergies passer de 20% à 5 5 voilà c'est
tout ça ce sont des mesures extrêmement
clair voilà vous ne vous êtes donc
vraiment le matraquage ou permanent
moi je le vois classiquement qu'est ce
qu'on a fait et et je sais pas quelle
somme bloquer les autres 12 mais on a
baissé la taxe d'habitation pour la
supprimant seulement la bc - la
supprimer et sa grosse moto pour chaque
thème est simplement délicieux
gâteau ça sera qu'une question de
revenus cette question au ciel de saint
servais localisation que voyez non
seulement et marine marine le pen
propose de baisser les taxes nous ne la
supprimerons
qui la taxe d'habitation et je pense que
la suppression de la capitation sépare
je pensé que je sais c'est un bain
pouvoir à shampoing
l'ailé
on a fait état de mesures ou entre
guillemets on a baissé les impôts
ménages chinois souligne ce qu'ils
disent c'est des chiffres on a supprimé
les taxes sans but on n'avait pas fait
mais jeudi jeudi par compte et par
chaîne et ils sont pressés que j'avais
raison vous avez passé bien sûr on est
plus rigide et vous avez baissé les
impôts des plus riches donc en passant
de l' isf à guy fille ça c'est vrai ça
c'est vrai que pour les plus riches ils
ont vu évidemment que leur feuille
d'impôt a été allégé en revanche pour
les classes moyennes et les classes
moyennes supérieures ça c'est sûr que le
fardeau s'est alourdi considérablement
et aujourd'hui vous avez une
paupérisation des classes moyennes qui
ne s'en sortent plus qui ne s'en sortent
plus pourquoi puisque tout augmente
l'électricité le gaz le les carburants
le le panier moyen tout augmente et vous
avez des familles notamment
monoparentales vous avez des mères
célibataires aujourd'hui qui souffrent
et qui n'en peuvent plus et au fatah
cela vous ne dites rien et vous ne
faites rien ouais c'est ça qui est
intolérable donc moi je veux bien qu'on
reste sur les statistiques de l'insee
moyenne ce n'est que je vois dans mon
département de l'yonne avec de plus en
plus de pauvres de plus en plus de
précaires avec des français qui sont
assignés à résidence parce qu'ils ne
prennent plus leur voiture ils ne
peuvent plus aller travailler et ils
font le choix au supermarché entre faire
le plein de courses et faire le plein
d'essence voilà la réalité de la france
de monsieur macron izik civile à le
mondial pour vous est-ce que vous avez
les uns intéressante ce fonds est la
question la question nationale chirouane
et je crois qu'il quitte les propos de
monsieur ni d'où l'on rejoint les propos
de monsieur mélenchon est pour moi là le
problème de la campagne d'un campagne
présidentielle en ville on verra comment
ça se passe mais pour moi c'est pas un
problème de droite ou de gauche il ya
des gens qui veulent plutôt
effectivement fermé les frontières qui
veulent se reproduire et les gens qui
sont ouverts d'un côté plus pouvoir
d'achat enfin cdi cdd il ya des gens dit
les gars des pessimistes a eu des propos
pessimistes comme je viens entendre et
puis l'autre côté il ya des gens au plus
tôt des propos optimistes avec
dissolution donc aux côtés jean fisse
ferme ali les propos pessimistes et des
gens qui sont plutôt au chrs optimiste
avec des propositions pour continuer à
améliorer la situation du pays et j'y
suis d'accord avec vous la situation des
classes moyennes qui pour nous est une
préoccupation merci à tous les deux en
tout cas où chacun a pu exprimer son
point de vue et c'est essentiel cyrille
isaac sibille merci d'avoir été avec nos
julien houle également et n'oubliez pas
si vous voulez